this is an electro bat what's an electro
bat you ask perhaps the love child of
batman on a wall socket or maybe a high
voltage vampire
actually no but it is something equally
surprising
it turns out new york city had a fleet
of electric taxis in 1895
yes 1895.
[Music]
at the close of the 19th century steam
gas and electric cars were fighting for
supremacy but electric was leading the
pen which is why a chemist named pedro
salaam and an inventor named henry
morris built an electric vehicle called
yes you guessed it the electrobat
pedro and henry took their creation to
the ultimate proving ground the hectic
streets of new york city where they
ended up part of the electric vehicle
company the first cab company of its
kind in new york and the world the
electra bat was a hit there were
hundreds of them zipping around midtown
they had a battery station on broadway
people loved them because you didn't end
up covered in soot
however
electric cars were almost twice the
price of their combustion counterparts
and they had a limited range
so eventually the startup failed at the
dawn of the 20th century taxis in new
york city were green
but clean or no the battery just didn't
have the juice to win the day
perhaps they should have tried out that
vampire
[Music]